بطولة ألفريد دونالد لينكس
هي أطول مباراة في جولة موانئ دبي
العالمية وتتميز أيضًا
بكونها منافسة الفريق الوحيدة
في التقويم التي يتم
لعبها بين فرق مكونة من
محترف واحد وهواة واحد يشهد هذا الحدث
بعضًا من أكبر الأسماء في  تقترن لعبة الجولف
بنجوم من موسيقى الأفلام
والرياضة
لإضافة لمسة إضافية ، حيث
يتم لعب البطولة على ثلاثة من
أكثر الدورات شهرة في اسكتلندا
كارنوستي
كينغز بارنز والملعب القديم في سانت
أندروز
بينما قد يكون لدينا ثلاث دورات ، هناك
مكان واحد فقط يجب أن يكون مرة واحدة  تنتهي اللعبة
كل يوم في الحفرة التاسعة عشرة الأكثر شهرة في
لعبة الجولف ، حيث ظهر Jigger
مع طقس اسكتلندا الذي لا يمكن التنبؤ به
في العرض الذي أقوم
باللحاق بالفائز العام الماضي
وبطل الماجستير لعام 2016 داني ويليت
لمعرفة ما الذي يجعل هذا الحدث فريدًا من نوعه ،
شكرًا لك فقط أعتقد أنه  كل شيء
حقًا من البداية إلى النهاية لديك
216 محترفًا رائعًا مقترنًا بـ 216
هواةًا رائعًا من جميع مناحي الحياة
ممثلو smen الرياضيون
والنساء والجميع يأتون للتو
والجميع ينبض بالحياة لأنهم يقضون
أسبوعًا رائعًا
كل يوم تسمع فيه الرجال الذين
تعرفهم أنك قادم
إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية واحتساء بيرة
وسيتحدثون  على وشك أن يلعبوا بشكل جيد إذا لعبوا بشكل سيئ ،
ما حدث وأنت تعرف فقط
أنها عطلة غولف مدتها أسبوع
لأول 500 شخص
وقد قابلت بعض الأصدقاء الجيدين حقًا
على مدار العقد الماضي ،
وستعرف الآن إلى الأبد
فلنتحدث  حول العنصر الممتع ،
ربما يكون ذراع Pro هذا هو الأكثر رواجًا بالنجوم ،
هل لديك أي نوع من القصص التي يمكنك
مشاركتها أو أي ذكريات أو جولات مع
بعض المستمعين الذين أعرفهم أن Dawn لا
يلعب هذا العام وأنا أعلم أنه فاز '  لا
تمانع في إخباره لكنه ليس
نعمة لاعب غولف جيد جدًا وعندما
أخرجت للتو 50 Shades of Grey ، لذلك
عندما تم إقرانني به كانت الفوضى
مجرد فوضى مطلقة ولسوء الحظ هو
ممثل أفضل بكثير مما هو عليه في الجولف
وهو فقط لأن  كان الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين يتابعوننا ، لقد ضرب عددًا قليلاً من
الأشخاص بكرات الجولف ، لذا أعتقد أنني
لا أعرف ما إذا كان سيعود الآن
لأنه يقول إنه يشعر بالتوتر الشديد عندما
يسير الناس على الجانبين ،
فسوف يضربه مرة أخرى.
أريد أن أنهي فقط بالسؤال لأنك
ذكرته سابقًا عن بعض
تجاربك هنا في الهزوة ،
ما هو الأمر الذي يشبه كل لاعب يسير في
الأسفل ، هل كنت مضايقًا من
الواضح أنك ذكرت شيئًا
جيدًا بعض ليالي السبت الجيدة
لا  كل ما في الأمر أنك تعرف ما هو
مجرد مكان اجتماعي رائع يأتي إليه
كل شخص تنتهي ، وهي
مجرد قاعدة غير مكتوبة أنه
في حوالي الساعة الثالثة صباحًا يبدأ الجميع
في التدفق على Jigger بعد أن
لعبوا الجولف لبضعة أنواع من البيرة
وبعد ذلك  مكان بداية رائع
لكل من لعب ، لقد قضوا
يومًا رائعًا يروون قصصك إذا تعرضت
للضرب ، فقد سلمت المال
لأنك خسرت رهانًا أو أيًا كان ما قد يكون
وهو مجرد مكان رائع
على الرغم من أن هذا هو بالضبط
هذا النوع من البقعة بالنسبة لي يجعل
الأسبوع بأكمله أفضل ، لذا فأنت تعلم أن
Jigger is The Jig هو ثاني حانة صغيرة لدي
مذهلة ، شكرًا لأنك فعلت السكر في
سانت أندروز لاندمارك المتمركزة بجانب
الحفرة 17 الشهيرة في  الملعب القديم
المعروف باسم Road Hole وهو
أشهر حانة في لعبة الجولف